[Musique]
bonjour à tous vous avez raté les
questions au gouvernement bienvenu dans
la séance de rattrapage le débrief au
menu en ce 19 mai le déconfinement une
semaine après leur est déjà un premier
bilan avec notamment cette question du
député lrm jean-charles larsonneur sur
le sujet dès tests alors que la france a
initié une sortie du confinement depuis
une semaine environ
pouvez-vous nous apporter des précisions
sur la politique de dépistage menée par
les services de santé
combien de tests virologiques sont
effectués par jour
quels sont les projections pour les
semaines à venir enfin sur les tests
sérologiques des douches de persister
sur leur fiabilité leur pertinence dans
le cadre de la stratégie de
déconfinement qu'en est il aujourd'hui
de ces tests et seront ils développer
pour devenir demain un outil
complémentaire dans la lutte contre le
la le hula lakovic 19
je vous remercie le nombre de malades en
circulation diagnostiqué par jour nous
permet d'aller amplifier encore
davantage notre politique de tests pcr
et je me suis entretenu avant de vous
rejoindre
avec les les représentants des
laboratoires pour leur proposer
d'augmenter des dépistages systématiques
dans des milieux particuliers tels que
des milieux confinés des hébergements
collectifs et voire même installer des
drive là où c'est nécessaire et y
compris sans prescription de sommes en
train de travailler avec eux parce que
nos capacités de test sont plus
importantes que le nombre de tests qui
sont aujourd'hui réalisées enfin sur la
sérologie la haute autorité de santé m'a
transmis une recommandation hier qui me
permet d'envisager à compter du début de
semaine prochaine de proposer à tous les
soignants de notre pays à l'hôpital en
ehpad en médico-social également en
ville de bénéficier sur prescription
diack d'un diagnostic sérologique pour
connaître leur état d'immunité nous
allons étendre ses indications également
à tout le personnel qui travaille dans
le domaine de l'hébergement d'urgence et
dans les lieux très collectif avec le
déconfinement l'activité économique
reprend petit à petit et certains
s'interrogent que va devenir le
dispositif de chômage partiel question
du député modem nicolas turquois à
muriel pénicaud
le 12 mai dernier la dares indiqué que
plus d'un million d'entreprises avaient
déposé des demandes d'activité partielle
pour un total de 12 points 4 millions de
salariés
ces chiffres sont colossaux et montrent
que l'état a su proposer une réponse
rapide et efficace au ralentissement
inédit de l'activité suite au
confinement
ainsi madame la ministre comment
envisagez-vous le maintien de l'activité
partielle à moyen terme
la décrue du chômage partiel a commencé
heureusement et donc il faut accompagner
cette reprise donc il n'est pas question
de faire un couperet il faut que le
chômage partiel de décroissent en même
temps que l'activité croise et que ce
soit plutôt des vases communicants un
système en biseau le taux de prise en
charge de l'état qui est très important
puisque c'est nouveau pour la france
d'avoir un tel niveau de prise en charge
puisqu'il est de 100% de remboursement
des entreprises jusqu'à quatre fois et
demi le smic commencerait à diminuer
début juin
mais évidemment pas pour les secteurs
qui ne peuvent pas fonctionner donc pour
les caves les cafés les restaurants mais
le touriste de façon générale et tous
les secteurs qui ont dépendent
massivement ils seront eux exonérés je
dirais de cette baisse de cette baisse
qui vise à encourager la reprise mais
qui n'est pas applicable dans les
secteurs qui sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt
complètement
et puis il y a le fameux monde après
cette promesse du gouvernement de
revaloriser les métiers de la santé
le député la france insoumise bastien la
chaux est monté au créneau sur ce sujet
mais vous allez le voir le ministre de
la santé le trouve un peu impatients
depuis deux mois
nos concitoyens applaudissent les
personnels soignants à leurs fenêtres
le pays entier le sait leur métier sont
indispensables ils méritent d'être
reconnus à leur juste valeur et pas
seulement par des symboles des médailles
mais par des actes une augmentation des
salaires des conditions de travail
dignes
enfin or votre gouvernement continue de
rester sourd à leurs appels
il octroie une prime exceptionnelle pour
la période de travail liée aux kovy
19500 ou 500 euros selon les
départements
pour les hospitaliers seulement
inégalité de traitement injuste indigne
quand les personnels ont été mobilisés
partout une prime et des promesses de
négociation c'est tout aucune annonce
concrète de revalorisation des salaires
précisément répondait monsieur le
ministre de combien allez vous augmenter
les salaires des personnels hospitaliers
ce n'est pas nous qui sommes souvent
monsieur le député lachaud
vous qui n'écoutaient pas ou qu'ils
entendaient ce que vous avez envie
d'entendre
puisque vous me posez une question en me
disant pourquoi ne voulez-vous pas faire
en parlant de quelque chose que nous
venons d'annoncer que nous allions faire
monsieur le député ensuite vous exigez
de savoir combien je vous croyais
respectueux du dialogue social et des
partenaires sociaux
croyez vous que ce soit à vous monsieur
la chaux au décours d'une question au
gouvernement que je vais dire expliquer
les choses sans avoir même pris le temps
de consulter les syndicats
ils seront réunis lundi au ministère
pour une première discussion
multilatérale et je crois que je leur
réserve leur aient la primeur des
échanges des discussions des
négociations s'il ya lieu et surtout des
annonces monsieur le député certains
secteurs sont plus touchés que d'autres
par la crise le député les républicains
julien aubert est élu du vaucluse un
département qui produit quantité de
fruits et légumes
or actuellement les producteurs manquent
de bras pour les cueillir le temps
administratif n'est pas le temps
économique
je suis je vous avais beaucoup de
pouvoir monsieur le premier ministre
n'est pas de pouvoir décaler la date de
maturation des fruits
nos cerises sont déjà très mûr et la
météorologie pluvieuse encourage la
prolifération des parasites dans mon
département on a trouvé à peine 500
saisonniers français pour 10000
recherché soit 5% des besoins pendant ce
temps là sur les étals des villes on
vend la cerise espagnol là je voudrais
que vous précisiez votre réponse quand
vous parlez de personnes autorisées à
travailler est ce que on consacre
concerne uniquement des ressortissants
européens ou est ce que ce sont tous les
ressortissants y compris non-européens
muni d'un titre de séjour
vous avez raison le temps administratif
n'est pas tant des saisons mais
aujourd'hui nous sommes bien dans le
temps des saisons et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le premier ministre a
rendu un arbitrage et l'instruction va
être publiée aujourd'hui et demain et il
y aura la possibilité de faire venir des
travailleurs étrangers avec un contrat
de travail
mais pour cela il ya quand même deux
conditions qui sont très importantes
la première condition c'est la sécurité
sanitaire on peut pas y déroger et le
guide des bonnes pratiques qui était
mise en place sera fait pour le travail
saisonnier quel qu'il soit mais la
deuxième solution qui pose plus de
problème et nous regardons ça de près
c'est évidemment pour le logement des
travailleurs étrangers vous savez très
bien
vous connaissez comme moi très bien
souvent les logements sont dans des
dortoirs ils sont les uns à côté des
autres très proches et ça ce n'est pas
possible
mais rassurez vous monsieur le député
robert dans les jours qui viennent la
main d'oeuvre étrangère pour être
là avec des garanties de sécurité qui
permettra à l'agriculture français de
pouvoir se développer et 26 produits
voilà donc pour cette annonce de didier
guillaume sur la question des
travailleurs saisonniers le débrief des
questions au gouvernement s'arrête là
pour aujourd'hui rester fidèle à lcp sur
le canal 13 de la tnt et puis suivez
nous sur les réseaux sociaux facebook
twitter
vous verrez c'est une autre façon de se
tenir informé on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine d'ici là portez vous bien